Have you ever had to tell someone that
they are best suited to a subservient
slash blue collar lifestyle because they
don't have any semblance of brilliance?
Okay.
Well I want to take issue with the
formulation of that question.
Although I think it's a perfectly
reasonable question.
That's Jen Swan.
Don't be thinking that a blue collar
lifestyle is necessarily subservient.
I mean,
first of all,
you can be a trades person and now it's
a really good career choice as far as
I'm concerned.
It's,
it's very,
very valuable in,
you know,
good plumbers are rare and good
carpenters are rare and good brick
layers are rare and they're so useful.
I mean,
I do a lot of renovation work.
I've done an awful lot of renovation
work on all the places that I've,
I've lived in and I've learned to do a
fair bit of construction and automotive
body work and all those sorts of things
and I really liked doing it and you
know,
there's,
they're blue collar life is not
necessarily subservient at all because
you can be master of your trades domain
and be unbelievably economically useful
and productive and creative and
independent and autonomous.
And so there's,
there's nothing necessarily subservient
about that.
Um,
now if you're thinking more about about,
let's say life at the low end of a
restaurant,
but even there,
if you're a conscientious person and
you're careful and you and you're awake
and you treat the people around you well
and you do your job properly,
there's also room for advancement in the
private sphere.
There's no reason to assume whatsoever
that merely because you don't have the
intellectual horsepower to work well in
the Abd,
in that in the domain of rapidly
shifting abstractions that your life has
to be a secondary quality or,
or,
or opportunity.
I don't see that at all.
And,
and there is endless opportunity in the
trades and,
and I can,
in Toronto for example,
there's a chronic shortage of
tradespeople and there's always a
shortage of qualified people for every
occupation.
So,
um,
if I have to tell someone that they're
best suited to a blue collar lifestyle,
I wouldn't feel bad about it.
I might say to them,
well,
look,
you know,
um,
let's assume you're talking to someone
who has an Iq of 100,
which is the Iq of the average high
school graduate.
You might say,
well look,
you know,
um,
unless you're super conscientious,
a,
a career in something like law is
probably not your best bet because
you're going to be competing with people
who have iqs that are like 30 points
higher than yours or 25 points higher
than yours.
And if you really work yourself to
death,
you might be able to main maintain
competitiveness in that domain,
but you're going to be working at a
powerful disadvantage because the people
that you're competing with,
for example,
are going to be way faster than you
verbally.
They're going to be able to read faster,
into reason,
verbally,
faster and and all of that,
and it might be better to pick a a,
a,
an ambition that's more in keeping with
the quality of your temperament and your
intelligence to to put it bluntly so
that you can be,
but that doesn't mean that your success
has to be limited and it it.
It also doesn't mean that I'm in
elevating intelligence to to the
platform of the ultimate moral ideal
because the relationship between
intelligence and moral ideal is zero.
There is no relationship between them at
all.
Intelligence is a,
is a capacity,
let's say that can be put to ill use
just as well as to good use and there's
nothing intrinsically better about smart
people.
They might be more useful for certain
things if they're oriented towards the
good,
but there's absolutely.
There's no shortage of opportunity in
the working class end of the end of the
world and I can certainly understand
often why people might prefer that to.
To the endless miasma you might say
chaotic,
Miasma of complex abstract jobs.
One of the problems with those sorts of
jobs is that you're never done.
It never finished.
There's always more work than you can
possibly do.